all right you guys the time has come
yes
Fitness leave
but work out are we doing today
your blood works today this is where I
come usually three or four times a week
really my opinion is the hardest workout
in LA yeah I've tried and tried almost
everything and this has been my favorite
and the hardest eating of it of pasta
I've thrown up a couple times so I'm
sweating
[Music]
hi I'm Julia and we are friends for 15
years that's a long time
so today I'm going to do Julia's
favorite workout we're boxing today I
box about three or four times every week
well the hardest workouts I've ever done
which is why I keep coming back I like
getting my ass kicked I'm gonna try my
name's actually uh Noah Williams
everyone calls me Shaq I started boxing
in college collegiately competing and
after I graduated I moved out to LA
where I linked up with an old friend
Leon found those love works and that's
why I started training there's not
really a lot of stuff that really
grasped my focus quite like boxing when
you're boxing you can't really focus on
anything else or wrong but the task
there's just like a family knit team
type feeling that we have here and it's
genuine boxing is both mental and
physical I love bringing my non-athletic
friends to work out it's just a reminder
how good a shape I'm in I'm totally
getting I'm totally kidding and then
you're a true expert I feel like I
always text you like random things like
what should I start doing and then you
literally send me a whole list of news
that I should try yeah do you ever do
them yeah you know I I do sometimes I
like the idea of boxing because it makes
me feel like I could be like strong and
powerful but like out in the world do
you feel more confident yes really and
nobody what I took a couple sparring
classes there and it's something that I
want to do more of cuz it's really fun
but yeah I was fired a couple of the
coaches and I got to punch one in the
face pretty good one he won't let me
live it down alright so let's do this
sorry ladies so we're gonna start
warming up with our feet and co-regent
first I want you to send a nice and tall
on the toes as you roll back on the heel
slight lean forward yep now we're gonna
hug the knees pulling the knees up hug
as you release heel down toe up and
scoop and alternate shots it's actually
my favorite part of the warmup it's to
help like warm up and lose
your hamstrings we just call it scoops I
seriously cannot balance doing anything
I don't understand what's wrong to me
I'm literally always trying not to trip
and look like before and relax good
we're gonna get some quad stretch is
going so grab a ball of that foot hold
it for about two seconds and switch
sides make sure you're breathing as
you're doing this always also I did not
shave my armpits so I'm a certified yoga
teacher so I have great balance Ella
could work on their balance love it but
you know a for effort
why are there so many things and fitness
that have to do with balance that sounds
really dumb coming out of my mouth right
now but I feel like I really need to go
back somewhere and get better about
because all these things are very hard
and they look very easy and frustrating
now we have some lunges so step back
with one foot into your lunge and then
rotate over your knee I don't know
I'm nervous alright so we're gonna keep
the simple again let's give it some
squats feet slightly wider than shoulder
width and you're gonna bend your knees
dropping your hips orange bands go
around the knees and the yellow bands
are gonna go around your ankles we're
gonna get into a squat position and we
have what are called monster walks
so in this flop position you're gonna
stay nice and low and you're gonna walk
forward to the walls walk forward yup
yeah good and stop and walk backwards
look I think that's how you girl but I
think if I grow toned but and the band
will definitely help to tone but down
chest up pressure on the heels I can do
squats all day and once we're finished
we're gonna hold hold that live squat
yep
oh my god
all right so we got some hip openers let
me see you move one meet inward and out
eat ten times on one side once you
finish your ten on the other side and
once you down relax take the band's off
now that we've warmed up our legs a
little bit we want to show this I need
you to take the whole of these yellow
bands and you're gonna put them around
your wrist once you get these bands
around your wrist I want you to open
your fist up to shoulder width apart
rotate your shoulders back from here
you're gonna give me five rotations
going all the way up and down nice now
we're gonna bring the arms up to higher
levels and we have 15 pulses okay so
your arms up stretching the band
slightly yep core nice and tight don't
watch the back yep and then we're gonna
go bump ahead fifteen pulses doing that
for the message feminism actually wasn't
as hard as I thought it would be alright
ladies so we have what are called inch
rims you're gonna do five inch ones your
feet are gonna stay stationary hands
come down for the ground walk all the
way out to a plank position pull and
walk all the way back out
hold and write I want you to stay out
there for this one for me to stay out
there in that push-up position we're
gonna hold you know the most frustrating
thing is trying to just hold your body
up that's hard for these planks what's
up hell why is that so hard it makes me
feel like a weak weak weak lame pilot
almost done this is in the last exercise
we're gonna do can we have some mountain
climbers and you're gonna bring your
right knee all the way up to your right
elbow keep the core nice and tight it
makes me feel a little bit like
spider-man doing those if you know gotta
work on flexibility and stability and
kind of a fun way to do it if maybe funs
not the right word but it's a way to do
the job nice and warm start boxing
yeah I won't feel ready so let's get
your gloves on you guys carefree is
verse or not doesn't matter they're over
there doing something that has my chance
believe alright here we are ladies we
got your gloves for the steak of the
newbie we're gonna go over some
foundational stuff okay so real simple
let's teach you how to stand first I
need your feet shoulder-width apart now
if you are right-handed take your left
foot and take one step forward we're
gonna bend the knees slightly and come
up to the chin now we have our first
punch all the jab order one your left
hand is gonna come straight out and aim
for your eye level and come back good
now we have our second punch just follow
the two we're gonna twist the right foot
like you're squishing a bug for me so as
you twist yeah punch with the right hand
now we're gonna try to hit these targets
let's start off with the one one and two
- I'm like looking over at Julia this
entire time being like one good one one
good - - nice good job now let's try to
put it together we got the one two one
two one two one two one two okay yeah
breathing is definitely part of it that
becomes that second nature once you've
been doing it for a while when I do
combinations I don't really think about
anything it's kind of a way to clear my
mind and just be super present in the
moment I have to pay attention or else I
might hit the coach in the face poor
shot straight fast go one two one two
nice one two once you want to want to
let's get six punches straight so one
two one two one two
nope good job it's hard enough you've
got a breeze I'm just kind of started to
learn some combos okay
and now the three is you need a book all
right yup and you're aiming for a target
at the side here we have the one give
the two and then two three good two
three all right now try to put three
punches together two three two one more
time one two together baby now you're
ready to punch one two one two three two
I like to uppercut to uppercut two three
- this is really hard like after I get a
little lightheaded
it can be a little overwhelming at first
now I want you to say to punch when you
go to God and say yeah one two one more
time you know what that's forcing you to
do is breathe yeah yeah I think my
biggest problem is forgetting to breathe
and then feeling things one two three
two roll take a quick break
oh you found so far huh good you know we
barely scratch it so first I'm getting a
little bet going up in here
some towels we got you get into a little
bit different workout of course super
important to boxing so we're gonna get
it a little bit forward it's called a
plank guru so we're gonna hold this here
for 15 seconds three two and alive
there's nothing like trying to hold up
your own bodyweight to really make you
question your abilities now leave you're
gonna turn and face each other on the
mat for me nice now before you get into
the point position once you guys to give
each other high fives with the same camp
so you're going to take your right hand
high five for it and then your left now
these are called alternate hypoxic heat
up good core nice and tight and try not
to rock the hip so you do this no safe
way over to the Machine this is called
the first requirement man diversify
where it is hard so place your foot on
the pedal that's on the ground grab a
hold of the handle on the same time once
you here place your opposite foot in
press it down and opposite hand
you sit down almost like you're sitting
on the stool so bend your knees and I
need you to bend your elbows also from
this position you're gonna work your
arms and legs so try not to move your
torso upward now there's a workout class
that's literally 30 minutes just doing
this with me I was on this for maybe 30
seconds max and was trying not to think
that's how you push I like it
so let's get back into the boxing if we
sometimes work for the versatile arm
right a little bit right bend the knees
and just not the gloves twice with one
two one two
three faster faster - I actually feel
really proud of myself I feel like I can
do this again thanks so much that was a
word I'm gonna sit down for two seconds
that was pretty great actually I really
like that yeah it's fun huh yeah I feel
like when I'm watching boxing and I'm
watching people punch it doesn't seem as
hard as it is I'm like oh they're just
punching but literally that was the
hardest part of the whole thing
it's such a fun workout though even
though I'm not like a fit person or like
an athlete I feel like it's something
that you could really learn and work at
and get better and feel really
accomplished and feel much stronger yeah
you can still train like an athlete
yes I want to try it again I think that
was really cool thanks for bringing me
yeah thanks for coming
I'm exhausted though I don't even think
I'm also I just have to say you are such
a badass like it's so crazy to see all
the combinations all the combos that was
amazing you are such a strong woman and
it's really inspiring
[Laughter]
[Music]